hice Larry here of Xbox Live's Major
Nelson down here in undead labs they are
the creators of state of decay which was
a surprise hit last year on Xbox 360 I
was blown away by the reception of the
community and how many of you guys were
playing it but great news for Xbox one
owners state of decay gear 1 survival
Edition is coming what is it where is it
how is it take a look
today we're announcing state of decay
your one survival edition which is the
definitive release of state of decay for
Xbox one
so steady decay is a zombie survival
fantasy game it mixes third-person
action role-playing game elements and
some strategy game elements into a
survival simulation put you in the
middle of the zombie apocalypse and then
allows you to make your own choices
about where and how to build your base
whether and how to recruit other
survivors to your cause and how to put
them to work how do you go scavenge for
resources and how much energy and time
do you put into that versus rescuing
people versus just fixing up your own
base it's a simulated world rather than
pre-scripted set of missions we're
allowing you to tell your own story
within the game by giving you the tools
you need to survive the apocalypse
the your one survival edition of state
of decay will have all of the DLC we've
released to date including the breakdown
and lifeline DLC it'll obviously be
remastered in full 1080p for Xbox one
and we'll also be including enhanced
animations enhanced effects really
taking advantage of the new hardware and
bringing it up the spec this is what we
do right this is in our DNA
the survival fantasy genre is something
that that I think when we look at the
future of the studio the future state of
decay you know that's who we are and
what we want to be doing and having a
relationship with our player community
is a big part of that they're very vocal
and clear about what they want and I
feel like we're very well positioned how
to be able to give them a lot of those
things for players who have already
played the game and who are looking for
something new we're going to have some
new content as a new mission types as
well we'll be able to share more details
about that as we get closer to release
which is currently scheduled for spring
2015 with the big announcement we had in
January about a long-term relationship
with Microsoft around the state of decay
franchise and also bringing on author
jail born to contribute to the future of
the franchise there's a lot of really
good things coming
you
you